tonight we begin at 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue where your buddy Joe Biden is
headed back to the basement his 2024
re-election bid is officially now
underway so I guess that means we can
expect to see a lot less of Joe than
usual and by the way uh it's official he
has given fewer press conferences than
any other president in the last 40 years
and according to NBC News it will be
several months before he even holds one
single campaign event and no doubt those
events will be few and far between he
didn't even hold a rally to kick off his
campaign today instead the Biden Camp
they released a heavily edited
pre-produced video attacking of course
Mega Republicans while attempting to
make Joe look lucid and capable in other
words everyone around him knows that he
is cognitively incapable of making such
an announcement without screwing it up
but that is a preview of Coming
Attractions now while Republicans shake
hands kiss babies take selfies they do
press Town Hall speeches put out
position papers whole rallies attend
debates Joe Biden will be hiding in his
bunker while his campaign floods the
Airways with negative ads and negative
campaigns and by the way Biden's
campaign strategy is to be out of sight
out of mind and it is unclear how he's
going to run another basement bunker
campaign because he doesn't have covet
as an excuse like last time Democrats
they have no other choice they say Joe
is simply too weak too frail such a
cognitive mess that he cannot pull this
off without it becoming a political
disaster as of now 7 out of 10 Americans
do not want Joe Biden to run for a
second term a majority of Democrats they
prefer somebody else and according to a
Harvard Harris poll nearly 60 percent of
Voters have doubts about Biden and his
mental Fitness and nearly 70 percent say
that he's too old to be president now
here's the very liberal editorial board
I don't often quote the New York Times
times they don't particularly like me
Biden should take voters concerns about
his age seriously the New York Times is
saying this the article notes what is a
glaring Omission in Biden's most recent
physical quote his cognitive abilities
went unmentioned the times continues if
he runs again Mr Biden will need to
provide explicit reassurance to voters
many of them have seen family members
decline rapidly in their 80s but mark my
words they will never ever ever be any
explicit reassurance at all he's already
refused to take a cognitive test and
publish the results you might recall
that President Trump did the very same
thing pass with flying colors his
results were great everybody knows that
Joe Biden would not do well because he's
a cognitive wreck you don't have to be a
brain surgeon for example here he is
today attempting to attack Republicans
take a look
the speaker the former president
and the Magnetic extremists were Cut
From a Different Cloth
they treat these folks
and they think they're a threat
they think that somehow
we're going to go back
the threat the American Republicans pose
is to take us to a place we've never
been
that's the best they can produce now
guess for us a short time later Biden
attempted to describe America's supply
chain take a look at this
folks look
I think how many people had no idea what
the hell heck a supply chain was
no I'm serious
you said
two two and a half years ago well the
supply chain people look at I mean
really bright people look at uh the uh
yeah the
well guess what because of the pandemic
and Factory shut down in Asia
they had no idea they were supplying the
essential material to us
I'm serious come on man now does that
seem like a guy who fully grasps the
complexities of the supply chain crisis
in the country now this is what you also
have to remember China president XI
Russia Putin Iran the malas uh Kim
Jong-un North Korea and all our allies
they're all watching this now his
troubles don't end there apparently Joe
is totally detached from reality now
today he proudly announced that his
economic plan is a massive success
except for all the bad things that are
actually happening that have nothing to
do with him take a look I know folks are
also struggling with inflation the first
pandemic disrupted the supply chain
causing prices to rise across the board
Putin's war in Ukraine
disrupted energy supplies and food
supply the Americans pay more for
prescription drugs than any advanced
country on Earth any advance for the
same exact drug our economic plan is
working we now have to finish the job
but there's more to do
all right Joe Biden is 80 years old he's
been in Washington in the swamp now for
over five decades he needs just a little
more time to perfect his economic Vision
just four more years that's it now in
reality Biden does represent everything
that is wrong with Washington his
economic his energy policies they have
caused economic troubles for almost
every American he is a career politician
a longtime grifter he takes his UH
responsibilities for nothing he blames
Trump for everything he's really never
worked a single day in the private
sector that we know of in his life
unless you count his role atop the
family uh Biden Syndicate that made a
ton of money but despite a variety of
llc's and shell corporations that
Syndicate is not really a private entity
is it since Biden public office it's the
sole commodity of The Syndicate now we
have many more developments on this
coming up in a moment but beyond the
blatant corruption Biden is known around
town for three things lying cheating
incompetence he's a plagiarizer a Serial
liar an ego bigger than his own brain
and worst of all to quote former
president Obama don't underestimate Joe
Biden's ability to F things up as
President Biden well humiliated American
Afghanistan he failed to deter Vladimir
Putin in Europe he won't hold China
accountable for anything not coveted not
the giant spy balloon that floated all
over Alaska in the continental U.S
collecting secret data about our nuclear
capabilities Right In Plain Sight and
meanwhile Biden pumped so much money
into the economy that inflation reached
the 40-year record high and is still
going up he also restricted oil and gas
production in this country that caused
Energy prices and the price of
everything you buy in every store you go
to to Skyrocket and of course energy
dependency on countries that we all know
hit our guts and despite all of his
vaccine and masked mandates while more
Americans died from covid uh under
Biden's first year under his watch that
under Donald Trump and let's not forget
the crisis at the border America's
immigration system is a train wreck and
he seems to want it that way because
he's inviting people in he's not
enforcing the laws of this country and
speaking of that supply chain that's a
train wreck the energy grid is a train
wreck the economy is a train wreck
America is less safe less secure less
prosperous and now Joe Biden wants to be
what rewarded with another term I think
America deserves better hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else